Speaker 1: Let's go to Thomas from.
Um, Thomas from Vietnam, I believe, is that
right?
Thomas?
Speaker 2: Yes.
How are you?
How are you doing?
I'm fantastic.
I've been a big fan of the show for over a
year now.
Thank you.
You're.
Speaker 1: What kind of a phone are you calling
through?
Because it is a very strange sound.
Speaker 2: I'm I'm I'm using a Shamie beautiful.
Right.
So I have two questions, the first one concerning
the Republican Party with the current state
of party, who will be the one who could actually
turn around the party and make it less of
a, you know, atrocity that it is now?
Speaker 1: I you know, there's just two ways
to think about that.
Yeah.
What Republican could get the Republican Party
out of Trump ism?
One school of thought it is that it has to
be a tried and true Republican.
Someone like, you know, Mitt Romney or something
like the return of Paul Ryan, for example,
has been talked about in that bucket.
I lean more towards something like the return
of Paul Ryan would be one possibility for
getting maybe the Republican Party out of
Trump ism in a slightly credible way.
The other path would be a new young cadre
of Republicans that are very different than
the Trumpy in one.
So not like Madison Cawthorn, not like Lauren
Bobert that that it should come from the youth
of the Republican Party.
The problem is the youth of the Republican
Party, from what I'm seeing, are suffering
from some pretty weaponized disinformation.
So I, I think that if you said to me Paul
Ryan's the type of guy who could maybe pull
the Republican Party out of Trump ism, I might
I might go with that.
I might at least think that's a plausible
idea.
Speaker 2: Well, I think we have to wait and
see, I would like.
Yes, certainly what my second question is
we don't know about, because I noticed this
recently in Vietnam, the has been a import
of confusion and a few Ananta, to certain
extent, because we all we are rolling out
that see nationally that are a lot of anti
vaccination movements going under the radar.
And it is connected with Trump supporters
also connected to a certain extent with multilevel
marketing as well.
So a lot of this community with the fly kind
of activities are being like.
To put together in this sort of of conspiracy
theories, anti vaccination kind of thing.
Know, how do we break that up?
Speaker 1: I don't know how we break it up,
but I love that you're bringing up multilevel
marketing because there is actually a big
overlap between anti AXA's and the types of
people that fall for Muslims and who often
there's Muslims that are Pseudo-Science.
So it actually is not shocking to me that
you would have Muslim people who think that
essential oils and who the hell knows what
will cure conditions, thinking that they don't
need to take the vaccine.
So I'm sorry it's happening in Vietnam.
I am going to let you go because the connection
is getting worse and worse by the second,
but that the connection between MLM and anti
VAX genuinely does not surprise me.
That actually makes a lot of sense.